foreign
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where that is dumb cash is
king and the paid off Home Mortgage has
taken the place of the BMW as the status
symbol of choice we help people
build wealth do work that they love
and create actual amazing relationships
Merry Christmas America we're glad
you're with us Christina Ellis number
one best-selling author Ramsay
personality is my co-host today as we
answer your questions about your life
and about your money open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five starting off this hour is going to
be Elena in Austin Texas hi Elena how
are you
hello hi Merry Christmas
hi this is Gloria
say again
Gloria my name is Gloria oh hi Gloria
I guess I pushed the wrong button let's
try something else let me try here four
Elena is that Elena hi Elena yes hello I
screwed up I hit the wrong button okay
what's up
better now how can I help
um I currently have about sixty thousand
dollars in my savings account and I'm
not too sure what to do next I
definitely want to make my money grow so
I no there's like a slow process where
you can do like a saving certificate but
I want to see if there's any other
options that will definitely help me get
um you know
um I get more money built up uh or such
well done where'd you get the sixty
thousand
so I've been saving since uh before
College
um and but it has increasingly went up
um with my full-time job that I recently
got
um and other side hustles that I've been
doing that just has helped me accumulate
them out
Elena that's amazing way to go do you
have any debt
no not at the moment I'm curious how did
you pay for college
uh with college I had um a ton of
scholarly scholarships I also had
private scholarships
um and then I would pay school if I had
any money that I had to owe from the
school I did have a part-time job at the
time where I would just use the money to
pay it off while also saving
you're amazing way to go that's just
incredible I love that just out of
curiosity for myself where did you get
that mindset how did you learn so early
on that you wanted to save aggressively
that you wanted your savings account to
look like that
well it all started when I first got my
job
um having I was paid cash so having that
money in my hands
um and being able to like see how much
it goes down with buying something from
the store just taught me that I I wanted
to have my hands full with money not
empty by just purchasing random stuff
and so the first thing that I saved up
for that was pretty big was a car
and I I was able to learn that you can
get mostly what whatever you want you
just have to look hard enough that's how
I was able to find my first car for
three thousand dollars and from there
that helped a ton since I didn't have to
do monthly payments or anything
so what do you do for a living
so right now I'm a data scientist I had
a uh or a car dealership yeah what do
you make
about 84 000. good for you okay so
here's the thing that we teach the
shortest distance between where you are
and being wealthy is a series of steps
maybe step one and save a thousand
dollars you've done that two is to be
debt free other than your home you've
done that three is to have an emergency
fund of three to six months of expenses
so we would earmark some of your sixty
thousand for your emergency fund uh we
could call that fifteen thousand pretty
comfortably as an example okay which
would still leave you sixty five
thousand dollars what are we gonna do
with that we're gonna move on to baby
step four and or start you earmark this
for saving towards a home either one
you're thinking about buying a home
anytime soon
uh I wouldn't see a home just yet
um I do have a partner and we're
thinking of buying a property so that we
can
um
make uh I guess rent it out with other
homes like mobile homes and such yeah I
would not do that
I would not do that don't buy real
estate with Partners if you want to buy
some real estate you buy the real estate
but you don't need a partner to do that
um
okay
you're going to involve yourself in a
mess that you're going to end up
untangling later the only ship that
won't sales a partnership
so I assume that you mean that kind of
business partner is that what you meant
no uh an actual relationship partner
okay well if you're not married to
someone don't buy a house with them
okay that's what I'm saying because
you're setting yourself up again for all
kinds of problems uh if this doesn't go
if this relationship doesn't go forward
so if you're married there's a
methodology called divorce that takes
the property and splits it up there's
not when you're not and so don't do that
now as far as then then what we would
just move on to is you're just an
investor okay you're either going to buy
real estate with this other 65 000 and
or you're going to start putting money
into your
uh into your retirement plan into good
growth stock mutual funds we recommend
that you put 15 of your income every
year at baby step four into a good
growth stock mutual funds into a
retirement plan and that's uh if you've
got a 401k at work you get the match
first if it's a Roth 401k you can stay
there otherwise after the match you
would need to move on and do Roth IRAs
and the mutual funds are growth growth
and income aggressive growth and
international you're looking for mutual
funds with long track records 10 20
30-year track records and you need to
learn about those as you're putting
money into that sit down with one of our
smartvester Pros they'll help you do
that the smart investor Pros don't work
for us but they're people that teach the
same stuff that we teach and they'll
help you with picking out the mutual
funds teach you that they're investment
Brokers you can find them at
ramsesolutions.com and click on Smart
investor Pro so
yeah that's a a
you know the process we would use to to
lead you there Hang on we're going to
send you a copy of The Total Money
Makeover book which outlines that for
you in great detail
So Christine the big the only the only
she had done so many things right but
she could undo every bit of it with one
wrong move and that's buying a house for
someone you're not married to or buying
a investment property with someone
you're not married to uh and
that will get you into a mess yeah we've
seen that several times and and I think
that's kind of a dangerous spot whenever
you don't have a proven plan it's easy
to start to get to that wealth building
spot and see all the tick tock praises
and see all the different you know quick
ways to make money and it's like you can
get really lost in that but Elena you
have done such an amazing job thus far I
love that you've been so aggressive with
your savings follow the plan it's not
the most flashy you know you know Tick
Tock crazy plan but it's proven it is if
we ought to put the plan on Tic Tac that
could be good
let's do it yeah I told the guys to get
get it get us a Tic Tac account and
let's get it on there I'm ready for it
so there you go this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
I've got it for years I've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds Shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller Shades or even outdoor Shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
Christine Alice Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five well here at
Ramsey Solutions we go all out to
celebrate Christmas we love it Merry
Christmas right hey that's why we're
giving you a surprise three-day year-end
sale on brand new products in the Ramsey
store that's three days of crazy low
prices on our most popular items right
now Financial Peace University gift
voucher
69.99 one of the best prices ever on FPU
right there Dr John deloney's
best-selling book own your past change
your future 12.99 Ramsay sweatshirts and
hoodies
all audio books are just five dollars
and that includes a Total Money Makeover
audio book you could listen to it as you
go over the river and through the woods
to Grandmother's house five bucks not
bad don't forget 2023 will be here in a
minute and if you want to grow
financially spiritually relationally
pick up the 2023 Ramsay gold planner
only
35.99 the lowest price it's ever been
can't believe those aren't sold out
that's weird Okay so so hey this stuff
is going like crazy questions for human
cards our three-day sale ends at 11 59
PM Central Time Thursday don't drag your
feet go to ramseysolutions.com store
check out the deals they are there for
sure
all right Gloria is now with us in New
York City hi Gloria welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hi and thank you how can we help
okay my question is I have a house and I
recently retired I'm 61 years old I work
for the board event for 20 and 27 years
and I still owe a mortgage on my house
because it was only me um it's only me
on the deed and um the mortgage is 164
000 bills and the 927 and um I have two
boys that live with me right now
um I was in the military he came back
home and the other one looks full of
Sanitation here in New York City but my
question is should I sell my home to my
children or should I put them on a date
so that I can take the equity out of it
because I can't I I had like 400 uh 400
and something thousand dollars in equity
but because of my income they said that
I can't like I don't know take out the
equity because I don't I don't earn
enough money and right now I went from
fifty six thousand dollars to 24 000 a
year
why did you go from 56 to 24 at 60 years
old
unbothered I'm not a teacher I'm an
assistant teacher so
um my um my incomes on my TRS is the
teacher's retirement it's done two
thousand dollars a month
when did you make 56 what were you doing
then when I was working because I was
working when I was working now why
aren't you working I
because I retired
okay but you have no money
you're you're saying you're 60 years you
said you're 60 years old right
I know the lab it was when I get when I
was working in the school and then when
I got um I got covered last year in
August and then when I came back
um to work I guess I was still feeling
the effects of the code I don't know but
um I just started for my retirement and
I left but I just want to know because
um since my children are working should
I show them the house or should I put
them just on the deed Gloria are you
wanting to use that 400 000 in equity to
live on or what's that equity for
the home equity because I wanted to I
wanted to take it to buy a house and um
in Florida
well just sell your house why do you
have to sell it to your kids just sell
it
and take 400 that take 400 000 and go to
Florida
so but and wouldn't it be better to um
to um I'm sorry I'm not really expert on
this but I'm just thinking about my
children since they live in New York
City already and they're your children
are grown they can make their own way
you're broke
I know you're broke you can't take care
of everybody else you're broke
they're like grown-up humans
okay and so you need to take this equity
and go to Florida you don't have the
money to give your children a house you
won't have any place to live if you do
but if I put them on the Deeds it
doesn't matter putting them on the deed
is not a magical formula it doesn't do
anything
if
no I do not want your children to go six
hundred thousand dollars in debt so that
you can put 400 in your pocket and go to
Florida
no I don't think your sanitation worker
son can afford this house
with your problems no this is a really
clean thing they need to start talking
about getting some housing because Mom's
about to move to Florida
no no they can't afford the house Gloria
and you don't need to saddle them with a
mess you need to just sell your house
they need to go get them a place to live
and be grown-up boys men and stuff
and you need to be in Florida and stuff
with 400 000 in the paid for house and
by the way you're only 60 years old you
probably need to be doing something
since you don't have any money
yeah that's what I was going to say I'm
worried about you I'm older than you and
I'm not retired you're okay you can do
it 60 year olds can still work well Dave
apparently
I've been here since early this morning
well Gloria you already have kind of a
sticky situation with your retirement
and getting covered last year and trying
to navigate all of that I would not
bring your family into this that's just
going to complicate not only the
financial aspect but the emotional
aspect of dealing with your sons and
them taking on a lot of your burdens I
would definitely keep those two separate
you know sell your house like Dave said
and then figure out what you're going to
do with retirement because I mean you're
61. I know that that may feel you know a
little bit older but you could
potentially have another 40 years like
you've got time and so we we need to
come up with a long-term strategy while
you still are physically able and you've
got a lot of great time ahead I mean
we're counting on Dave for another 30
years though
you got a While You Can Count On Dave
going to Cabo at some point Dave
oh my gosh yeah that's what you need to
do honey don't you're trying to get this
house to do too many things it's not
capable of undoing but one thing
and it takes care of you that's all it's
capable of it can't take care of you and
your kids have a place to live there and
you get money out of it it's trying
you're trying to make one thing work too
hard just sell it let them get them a
life and you go to Florida and start
your new career that's what I would do
if I woke up in your shoes Brandon is in
Spokane Washington hey Brandon welcome
to the Ramsey Show
hey thanks for having me sure what's up
um so me and the wife we're I'm 23 right
now
um we just got finished up with baby
step three so we got our six month
emergency fund we don't have any kids or
anything We're just trying to figure out
where do we go from here do we start
saving for a house I know we are kind of
enjoying some money right now
um I'm just curious if we stay gazelle
intense and gave up all we can for a
down payment or
what do we do is that your next goal to
buy a house
um I believe so we're hoping yeah we
hope to have a kiddo here sometime in
the future and
just trying to
I don't know want to prepare ourselves
for the future so well that's great well
we would call that baby step 3B where
you save up your down payment for your
house we don't want you to stay there
forever but I mean if that is a goal and
you're wanting to bring the baby home
into a house that you own
um then yeah go ahead and start saving
in that and then of course after that
you know your baby steps four through
six where you're going to start saving
for retirement your kid's college fund
and then paying off that house
I have a feeling you already knew that
I um like after a baby step three would
be baby step four you knew that
yes
yeah
um we're just you know enjoying a little
bit of the money and that's why you said
that so you're spending everything now
not quite worth it again we got eighteen
thousand dollars put away into our uh
our six-month emergency fund that's your
emergency fund and now if you want a
house you're gonna have to quit enjoying
so much
yeah you know new goal new goal be
intentional uh don't just kind of wander
off into stupid land again you just you
just visited there and um you don't want
to live there that's why you walked your
way out don't go back so stay very
intentional very focused keep on the
game plan yes you can enjoy your money a
little bit we don't have to go down to
beans and rice rice and beans you're
past that now but you do need to be
intentional and I have no money past my
emergency fund three years from now
because I've been enjoying my money is
not a plan this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you that's why you need to get
in touch with Churchill Mortgage to make
sure you do this right these guys are
awesome they'll help you get on a
smarter mortgage plan because they're
committed to doing what's right for you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsay trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
Ty number one best-selling author is my
co-host today
her book confessions of a scholarship
winner because she's a winner uh big
deal a big deal because she got five
hundred thousand dollars in scholarships
so she's our one of our resident experts
on uh student loan mess student going to
college debt free not falling into the
Epic trap of student loans and so as we
all know well most of us know by now uh
President Biden has been attempting to
forgive ten thousand dollars worth of
student loan debt 20 if you're a Pell
Grant recipient and uh so far has not
been able to pull off that idea
in two years
um the latest version is that the
that it was that the whole idea of him
being able to forgive debt was not legal
and so it's taken to court
and uh so it's in court and they um been
kicked all the way up to the Supreme
Court and the Supreme Court has agreed
to hear it uh in February and it comes
out today that will be February 28th
of course our Judicial System always to
picking the last possible day to do
anything so they're going to put it off
as far as they possibly can
um slower than Christmas oh wait a
minute Christmas is already here yeah
okay that came up fast so uh so a number
of conservative backed lawsuits arose
seeking to block the relief and two have
the two of them have temporarily
succeeded thus far one lawsuit filed by
Six republican-led States argued that
that relief would hurt their State's tax
revenues and uh that of missouri-based
student loan company uh the other
lawsuit was filed by two student loan
borrowers who sued because they did not
qualify for the full twenty thousand
dollars of relief
oh okay and
uh two lower courts that received each
of those cases ruled the Biden's loan
forgiveness plans should remain on pause
until the Supreme Court makes a final
decision on the legality of the relief
and now it has gone to a supreme court
of course in the Supreme Court today
comes out and says we will um
I will be taking on both lawsuits The
Challenge on February the 28th you know
I can't I don't know what taking on
means
does that mean they're going to rule on
that day or they're going to start the
process of hearings on that day that was
gonna be my question because my first
thought is woohoo
said that over and over again where I'm
like okay we have a date we have a date
for when the pause ends we have a date
when people will know exactly what to do
next and then we don't have dates that
are somebody's foot is sore from kicking
the can so much right yeah you think so
it's like is the 28th the date you think
that they're going to rule on it or is
it just going to officially start a long
time they're taking it this is Yahoo for
you but I mean
the nation's highest court announcer
will be taking on both lawsuits the
challenge we knew that I just saw
another article that says they were
they'll hear hear oral arguments that
day they're okay so they're going to
begin the process that day so six or
eight more months
maybe if we're lucky or you're lucky or
you're not lucky here's the thing
um we told you when this first came up
that before it came up that it was going
to come up
uh we told you what was going to happen
um and uh We've we've predicted every
step of the way on this and all along
the way have been telling you to pay
your student loans exactly just because
the government is kicking the can down
the road does not mean your life should
be handed on hold right you need to
clear your life get victory over this
area of your life and move on with your
life you sit around wait on the
government to fix your life your life's
always going to suck
so you can't do that you've got to lean
into this and you got to say this is my
deal I signed up for these loans I'm
going to pay them now right and it's
just going to be much better for you if
you've got the loans I'm all feel dumb
if the government comes no you won't
you'll feel proud that you actually
honored your obligation
that's not dumb yeah I've seen so many
people in my Instagram DMS just cheering
that they paid it off even with the the
carrot dangling of forgiveness they're
still proud of themselves for having
paid off those loans so it's like if you
do not like that anxiety if you don't
like that feeling of being at the whim
of a government in the student loan
forgiveness pay off your loans like just
get it done yeah you don't have to stay
in this space of unknown of Perpetual I
promise you someday ugh by a politician
um buy a court system
it's going to be forever it's going to
be forever don't wait on forever don't
don't please don't wait any more pay it
off now Eric's in Houston Texas hey Eric
what's up hi uh Dave this um I just
started listening to you not too long
ago I have a friend that uh that did
your program and you know is out of debt
uh I have a question my wife and I were
um we're she's believes in having no
debt so we're going into this
um but I've already you know calculated
how much you know you know uh credit
card loan I I that I have
um here's the thing I we have five
properties right uh three of them are
rented out one of them is where we live
and another one I'm going to start
running it out because you know it was
kind of like out in the country weekend
but we don't get out there so I'm either
gonna put it up for Airbnb or uh rent it
out to someone that lives out in that
area
once when I've added all my my debt I
have two mortgages right two loans for
but five properties but two loans for to
pay two of these properties do I treat
those two loans that uh as part of a
snowball you know do I bump them in with
that or I mean how would I how to tackle
that your personal residence is paid for
yes okay how much non-mortgage debt do
you have
uh 20 21. cool what's your household
income
um so my wife just started working again
so I make 80. um but my wife makes uh
she's transitioning the position that
hopefully will get her you know 50 60s
but right now I mean I'm creating it as
if she's bringing in 35 a year so I
would say you don't have to treat it
anyway it's just what she is making her
in making so yeah right now she you make
80 and it sounds like she's gonna make
60 or at 140. you're gonna pay off 20
very quickly if you freaking behave and
lean into it and uh now your other two
properties your home is paid for but
your other two properties what's the
balance on those debts so uh I actually
got a home equity loan on the property I
live in it was paid for and then I guess
oh so your home is not paid for
so the one I live in right now yeah
that's your home yeah yes it's not paid
for
no it has a loan on it
yes okay how much
uh
160. okay cool and what's the other debt
the other mortgage uh 143. cool all
right what we would do is put those both
in baby step six
okay and address those as you get there
and I would pay off your house first
then I would pay off the rental
okay what did you say is the 21
000 in debt credit cards uh it's credit
cards uh and I've got I've got
um about 13 in the bank that I'm going
to put 12 into okay um that and then um
I when I do my taxes I always get money
back because I deduct more I don't know
if that's a smart thing to do but no
it's not
um so I'm I'm you're loaning the
government money all year with no
interest
and they give it back to you and you act
like Santa Claus lives in DC
yes yes yeah so go ahead and go ahead
and set your withholding up properly
where you don't get a refund and you
don't have to pay but you try to aim it
as close to your actual proper amount to
be withheld uh because a refund is
simply a loan interest-free loan to the
government
married because he said something
life is about no debt and I'm curious
has he decided that he's about no debt
because that's a very interesting
distinction that his wife doesn't
believe in debt does he I mean because
this that's a quite a few different
loans and and mortgages
he had decided to get out of that and
then she got on board maybe I
misunderstood but well I I hope that
would be my question is just making sure
y'all are on this is the guy who went
and got a home equity loan to buy rental
property and that put his home at risk
again so yeah but yeah you just drop
that all over all your real estate stuff
over in the baby step six and get it
paid off there the great news is you
make good money and if you lean into
this you can be 100 debt free houses and
everything in just a few years you'll be
amazed this is a Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Christine Alice Ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today Jay is with us in Boise
Idaho Merry Christmas Jay how are you
oh I'm well how are you better than we
deserve what's up
hey so earlier this month we were
rear-ended in a car accident and
thankfully no major hospitalizations or
injuries but the car is most likely to
be totaled um we're now on day 19
waiting for insurance to let us know wow
but uh my question my question for you
is
um we bought the car in 2020 before uh
it's our BD before Dave's days and uh we
o Aid on it
um it's worth um if they total it I
believe it's worth between 14 to 15 000.
um so we're thankful for that in the
market
um but we're gonna need to replace it
and I just want to know the wisest way
to do this uh we do not have the cash to
pay for a car and we
we just need advice yeah um
well it it
um you've been through a pretty
traumatic thing getting hit that hard is
a big deal
um and it kind of makes you think oh I
need to do this or that and uh you're
obviously trying to get out of debt
correct
correct we're we uh we had our um
our anger moment was was in October okay
and that's when we got intense and so
we're brand new on this we have our
we're we're in baby step two we have our
thousand dollar emergency fund how much
yeah do you have other than the car
that's 30 on what
uh uh it's all consumer it's credit and
then the eight for the car is included
in that I'm sorry you set aside from the
car
it's about 20 a little over 20 000 and
it's credit cards okay all right cool
uh
well done yeah what's the process look
like with insurance right now so you
said that you've been waiting 19 days
what's their correspondence been like do
do like are they in the process of
evaluating
well yes
um they are uh they I'm working with the
at fault insurance and um they are I
don't talk to them unless I call them
and um I think I've talked to her twice
but she the ball is rolling she said
they're waiting on um
uh uh estimates
um from your their uh their person and I
actually missed a phone call from I
think it was from her while I was on
hold for you so I think they're at the
process where they're ready to tell me
it's totaled uh or they're gonna fix it
we're in a rental car that they're
providing and the the day they total it
we have four days I am not in a hurry
I'm this is not we don't we are not in
panic mode we have family we have
friends we do not have to go buy a car
what's your other car within those
my vehicle is a four passenger it's a
Ford Focus our five passenger we have we
have seven in our family though um so as
far as being able to
um uh borrow a car we could do that in
the short term no I wouldn't uh if you
had to for a little bit but until you
find a deal okay
um
this is going to sound bizarre so I'm
gonna go ahead and say that out loud but
it is also exactly what I have done and
what I would do if I were in your shoes
the goal here is not short-term comfort
the goal here is live like no one else
so that later you can live and give like
no one else so I'm going to use this
situation as an opportunity to pay cash
for a car with the equity that you get
out of this car so it sounds like
they're going to give you seven or eight
thousand dollars I'm gonna go buy a
seven eight thousand dollar car
okay
and that I got rid of your car note
so you just paid off a bunch of debt and
the the the only way you can do this
and fight through the emotions of what
I'm suggesting is to really tell
yourself the truth and the truth is this
is temporary
yeah not that long okay so what's your
household income
75. so how quick do you pay off the
remaining 20 do you think
our our uh every dollar estimate is is
looks like it's going to be 23 months
that's too long
was what you make I was thinking about
10 months
so I think we need to cramp down on the
budget and uh maybe pick up some extra
income from somewhere uh maybe even look
for something else to sell but I want
you out of debt and about so that you're
buying a better car
with an up as an upgrade with cash by
this time next year is what I'm thinking
well I want to encourage you that for
a thousand dollars if that car gets
totaled and you get that amount you can
still get a decent no no it's not he
owes eight right and if he gets 16.
that's going to be eight in his pocket
if he gets 15 it's gonna be seven in his
pocket so you can still get a pretty
good car for seven that's what I want to
do yeah literally before this year I'd
never bought a car over ten thousand
dollars and I've been driving just fine
guys
it's a long time for a long time simply
because I'm free but the point is you're
moving it's hard emotionally to move
with little kids down from a 15 000 car
to a seven thousand dollar car fourteen
thousand dollar car down to a seven
thousand dollar car but if you if you
remind yourself over and over and your
family that this is for a year temporary
this is an adventure it's a one-year
thing or a 14-month thing or a eight
month thing whatever it is when you can
lean in on this and get it done fast
then you can move up in car with cash
and so I can drive a junker for a period
of time well that's part of the
motivation too is you know to get it to
go from 23 months down to 10 is remember
that it's just a season and the more
aggressive you are the quicker That
season passes Josiah's in Tulsa Oklahoma
hey Josiah what's up
hey Dave and Christina good to talk to
you guys you too how can we help
so I have two job offers for emergency
department uh physician jobs finishing
residency here in Oklahoma so my
question is job one is uh an independent
contractor it'd be all self-withholding
um that you do on yourself and then job
two is a contracted position that would
come with Benefits now I'm in the unique
situation I'm in the Army Reserve and so
I get a lot of my benefits and health
insurance through that but I'm kind of
wondering of what questions I should be
asking or what I should look into
of kind of is one better than the other
and obviously if they were they're both
self-employed positions are they not
so uh there one is one is more
self-employed it's still with a contract
but they just it's kind of a 1099
position where the other one's going to
be a W-2 so yeah oh it is a W-2 so
you're actually an employee on the other
one okay correct yeah so uh is the money
this similar or
no so that's the that's the kind of
caveat between them so job one that's
the independent contractor uh
everything's hourly in this kind of
field and so it's like 225 an hour
whereas the other one with the benefits
is 200 an hour and so that's why I'm
kind of is there a is there kind of a
threshold that you get to where well you
don't need the benefit better than the
other
correct I don't need to benefit so it's
mostly for kind of the 401K and being
able to have that you know you know 401K
versus an IRA if I can put more into
that you know vehicle than the other
well you can still say for retirement
even if you're not a W-2 employee yeah
but if he's not W2 you can't do 401ks
what are you saying right you're limited
to eight thousand dollars so instead of
19 going into your 401 you can do a
self-employed 401K right
yeah you could that's true you could do
a sap
um and you can get just as much in there
so the other question is which good
catch uh the other question is which
um of these two places would you rather
work if everything was equal
so I actually am leaning more towards
the the lower paying one the reason for
that is it's due to the
um I can do 24-hour shifts there versus
12 hour shifts just because of the um
the patient load
um that comes into they're both in kind
of rural places
um and so it kind of I feel like I can
knock out a whole bunch more hours you
know and be away from the family kind of
less days of the month than working you
know 12 hour shifts where it's still
kind of a full day's work
I'm probably choosing the lifestyle over
all the other issues you brought to the
table first
okay because both of them are great
money both of them you're going to be
believing you're going to be living your
dream in terms of this is what you've
been working for all this time
um and I'm not gonna let a 401k dictate
or a lack of a 401k dictate uh a bad
lifestyle situation so I'd rather pick
my family and because they're very very
close
um so I I'm gonna go with that one if
I'm you the one that you feel like is
going to give you the best quality of
life so good question sir we appreciate
you joining us
thanks for being here that puts this
hour of the Ramsey Show in the books
[Music]
have you been inspired to make a change
with your money want to know where to
start take our three-minute money quiz
to get a plan you can follow go to
ramsesolutions.com and search for get
started to get a plan for your money
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS of
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where Ted is dumb Cassius
King in the paid off Home Mortgage has
taken the place of the BMW as the status
symbol of choice we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships Christina
Ellis number one best-selling author
Ramsay personality is my co-host today
as we answer your questions about your
life and your money open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Merry Christmas America we're glad
you're with us Emily is here in
Springfield Missouri hi Emily welcome to
the Ramsey Show
hi thank you so much for taking my call
sure what's up
okay so for a little bit of context I am
almost 21. my husband's almost 23. he
works full-time and I am a stay-at-home
mom to a six-month-old we don't have any
student loans or credit card debt we
don't believe in credit cards as well
um um so we only have a car loan and two
phone payments totaling less than
fifteen thousand dollars and I'm trying
to convince my husband to do the baby
steps because he really just doesn't
believe me that they can work
do I do that what do these conversations
look like so so you say hey I've heard
of this guy Dave Ramsey
there's these things called the baby
steps what's his reaction
well I'm sorry
I showed him like 30 minutes the other
night and he just didn't believe that it
was possible
um
what's the tears for
it's an ongoing fight in our
relationship
it sounds like it's
it sounds like money is an ongoing fight
so what's he do for a living
he just works at an industry like a
factory company
that what and so where is it that he
became a financial genius
at 23 freaking years old
yeah so I don't know I don't either I'm
really confused about where his
arrogance is coming from
or even his confidence
I just want to be financially free not
you know that this is what I need and
he's like well I don't want you working
but I'm like I'm willing to work and he
changed jobs because the other one
didn't
um
it didn't have benefits and so we needed
benefits for our family being a single
income and it didn't have overtime as
well and so we switched jobs so that way
he could have over time
and he still doesn't like over time he's
never taken an hour off or extra to work
and I've encouraged him to do so because
our son
um he won't remember this time in his
life because he's with me six months so
I'm like we need to be paying this stuff
off so that way we can save up first us
in the future
but um he just doesn't think it's
possible
what does he make
um right now it's like less than 18 an
hour
hey Emily I'm wondering are y'all
connected to a church
yes we are
do y'all have any mentors in the church
yeah we've reached out and they just
kind of let us down on that
I would try again I think you all need
some community in your lives to really I
think that this is beyond just a
financial issue it sounds like a bit
like a marriage issue um y'all are 21
and 23 years old and those first few
years of marriage they're hard and you
need some wisdom in your life you need
people speaking into that marriage
because it does sound like he's pretty
resistant and maybe what he won't hear
from you he can hear from an older man
who's had some years of experience and
can pour into him because I mean it's
hard sometimes in those years and I
think just having some of those outside
conversations could help
yeah and um we have tried to teach
um to search out counseling at our
church but it cost money and he's like
well I don't want to pay for counseling
but I'm telling him like it's our
marriage you kind of it's either you pay
for this or there's no marriage
um
those are some serious conversations I'm
I'm curious you guys are in Springfield
um let's try to get them into a
Financial Peace University class even if
it's not at your church just because I
want you to be around other people who
are winning with money who are winning
in their marriages who are winning in
relationships and a lot of times in
those communities people are not only
walking out the baby steps but they're
becoming friends they're pouring into
each other's lives and I think you guys
need to be surrounded by good influences
right now and I'm so sorry you've been
hurt by the church that you've been hurt
by the people who you really trusted to
pour into you but I wouldn't give up
um there are amazing communities out
there so hang on the line we're gonna
have Austin pick up and try to connect
you with a local community a local FPU
community and you know we'll pay for it
for you guys to go through it
yeah and um
this is going to blow up
if you don't if he doesn't hear you
because you're really close
to flipping the switch and being done
um you've about had it in your sweet
little voice I can hear an amazing
amount of anger and resentment towards
this prideful husband of yours
um
so yeah I mean he's
doesn't want to go to counseling he
doesn't want to work overtime he doesn't
even want to watch a YouTube about how
to handle money when he makes 18 an hour
um and he's 23 years old so I mean this
guy's he's got
um he is going to get
um he's either going to choose
to learn some new things or they're
going to get forced on him by his
stubbornness he's getting ready to get a
knot knocked on his head by life
um and I um yeah his
yeah somehow you you need to get someone
to coach you a pastor a counselor or
somebody on how to speak to him because
honey you're close to being done with
him and we're not even I know how these
things come down once you have had it
you will be done and we won't be able to
get you back
to him and no matter what he does
because he he and he's
not wise enough to ascertain how
how far in the hole you are right now so
you're going to have to get somebody
there to help you kiddo but hang on we
will get you into Financial Peace
University for free it's hard to argue
with that what can it hurt we're sitting
here watching Netflix anyway so we might
as well get up off our butt and go down
to the church and go to a class and if
you'll just do that dude
um we can help you but um I can't help
you know
you can um I mean you can hit a horse
with a two before but it won't make him
drink
ouch you've seen me stories Dave over
and over again where there's a very
resistant spouse it doesn't it doesn't
end well have you ever found like any
type of like I don't know there's no
magic formula yeah I mean to you know
but what ends up happening is if you
just stand in the Middle Road and defy
life it will run over your butt you know
and he's gonna get his little butt run
over that's what's gonna happen because
he's just shaking his fist at everything
and uh he's gonna get his fist broken
that's what's going to happen so here we
go and I hope not I hope he can come
around sooner than that I'm afraid I
know this guy I might have been him in
another life this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
with health care costs Rising learn how
Christian Healthcare Ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry it's
worth it
foreign
[Music]
thank you for joining us America
Christina Ellis Ramsey personality is my
co-host today so if you're 23
43 53 73
one of the
Hallmarks
of people who live a high quality
life
is that they are perpetually curious
about things they don't understand
or have experience with or knowledge of
and
um especially an area of your life that
is bringing you pain
and so when I had babies and we brought
them home from the hospital
they did not send me a manual
I had no idea
what to do
um
I mean I had
been raised by humans so I had somewhat
of a idea there right I mean I had
people in our life that were around us
but I did not know how to be a parent at
23 years old
so
I could just
blindly walk into that
with arrogance and pride and say well
it's my kid I get to decide which that's
a true statement it is my kid I can do
get to decide or I can start reading
books on parenting I can start taking a
class on parenting I can
watch videos on parenting and I can
agree with or disagree with what I'm
seeing and thereby start to form out of
my curiosity
my own process which is exactly what I
did and I raised three kids that are all
successful
adults
and so far are raising successful
grandkids those kids are raising kids so
but I didn't know anything about it but
I didn't just start out as young and
dumb and stay that way right you're you
are the walking example of that curious
person but what what if somebody's not
like can they no you can decide to be
curious right you can decide to be oh
I've got all this figured out
at any age but if you're sick listen if
you're broke
please don't tell people about your
opinions on money
you should be very quiet
because you're apparently wrong
if you have been divorced six times I
don't want to read your book on marriage
you shouldn't be telling people how to
do relationships you suck at it
you know I mean if if you're 450 pounds
don't write a book on physical fitness
that's ridiculous and I don't care what
your age is that's just stupidity and
pride
and so there's things today at 63 years
old that I don't know about but I'm not
going to pose as an expert on those
things
and and become belligerent
with my wife about those things so
that's what that young man in that last
call is facing the the antidote to him
or for him he's going to have pain in
every area of his life because he's
going to approach every area of his life
like he is right now with fear and anger
and stubbornness rather than curiosity
and curiosity goes you know what I don't
know
but by God I'm gonna find out I mean I
started going to church as an adult I
didn't know anything a preacher would
say and you know when they threw
Joseph's brothers threw him in the hole
and I'm like nope don't know Joseph
don't know the whole but I will find out
by midnight because I don't like being
the dumbest guy in the room I'm gonna
get open that Bible and figure that out
and that's how I started studying the
Bible I didn't like being the dumbest
guy in the room and so I'm curious I'm
going to find out what this means I'm
going to find out why there's 73 brands
of Christianity why is why is it we have
like 63 brands of Baptists you know I
want to know these things
what is the difference in a free will
and a missionary I want to know I want
to know why that happened how is it that
the Church of Christ is born out of the
Christian church I want to know how the
United Brethren Church ends up being the
United Methodist Church why'd they drop
Brethren I don't know poor Brethren the
I want to know
you know and you got to get it you know
but if you already assume I've got it
you know I'm the complete package at 23.
that's so ridiculous it's funny
right yeah were you always curious or do
you feel like you had to go through your
you know obviously the bankruptcy and
all the hard knocks you got before you
got curious like well this 23 year old
have to get smacked in the face I think
my point is it's a choice
you know if the point is if something in
your life
is not working
you've got
overwhelming anxiety
you need to be curious about anxiety and
be reading
delony's book redefining anxiety and
listening to every podcast of deloney
right and learning about people in the
mental health field and learn the the
wide variety of opinions about things in
that world and you know start to
identify but you can't just go oh I kind
of like my poop I'm just going to sit in
it
you're like you're like you're a toddler
you know and and so this decide
if an area of your life is not working
to be curious It's a decision that's my
point so I'm putting myself in that 20
year old 21 year old shoes hearing this
and being like yes he needs to decide
like how if you're that person we all
know that person who is just they think
they're right about everything even
though they're completely ignorant they
have no clue and we've wanted to talk to
them but we just can't get through to
them like you can't you can't make other
people behave but I'm just my I'm
pointing out though that that
you know find success principles
and one of the if you want to be
successful that is if you want to be
average average in America is not bad if
you want to be mediocre you can get
through this life doing very little
and being very little and you don't
you're very seldom hungry I mean you're
gonna be okay but I mean if you want to
have a sense of traction a sense of
success in your marriage in your
parenting in your money in your mental
health in your career if you want to
have a sense of traction a sense of
progress that then you are going to
decide to be curious in those areas I
can't make you be curious I'm just
telling you that that is a a necessary
element to having a high quality life
and so and you can you know Integrity is
also a necessary element and that's
that's not a you know how do you make
someone have integrity you don't they
just decide as of this moment I'm going
to have fanatical integrity
because there's a high correlation
between that and people who have high
quality lives and so it's a freaking
decision
and and so you know and you can do that
sometimes you people make it all the way
to 63 or all the way to 53 and they're
still just bullheaded and stupid and
argue with a wall about when the
evidence is in front of them that they
don't know what the crap they're talking
about
you know so if your broke friends are
making fun of your financial plan you
are right on track
hello they're stupid they're broke
that's I mean they're they're they're
stupid in the money area you know if
your fat friends are making fun of your
weight loss program you know you're
right on track
don't do that I would just eat whatever
I want well I got I did too I blew up
like I got so fat during covet it was
unbelievable ate every donut in a 50
mile radius and so you know if I hang
out at Dunkin Donuts guess what this is
going to happen again
so you know you got to decide these
things
it's a success principles need to come
from people who are successful in the
area
not people who are failing in the area
with an opinion
so Dave let's role play for a minute
let's pretend like the 23 year old
husband was here on the line what would
you tell him what I just did for the
last 20 minutes yeah smack him around no
I mean that's it it's not I'm not
smacking him around I'm loving loving
the guy
[Music]
back around
after talking to her everybody wanted to
but right you know he he scared and he's
angry and his answer to everything is
bull up on it and try to prove but I'm
just telling you dude your track record
sucks and you're not winning in your
marriage you're not winning in your
career and you're not winning in your
money so you probably ought to get
curious about all three of those things
whether you're 23 33 or 83 it's time to
change something that's a word
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
Christina Ellis Ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life and your money
our question today comes from blinds.com
find out for yourself whyblinds.com is
the number one online retailer of custom
window coverings you get free samples
free shipping and with the new promos
they run every month you'll save even
more use the promo code Ramsay to get
the best deal today's question comes
from Michael in Florida I'm recently
faced with a dilemma for baby step five
I'm currently in the position where I
can either take thirty thousand dollars
and put it in a prepay plan for my state
Florida or take that money and invest it
in a 529 plan College Prepaid Plan has
the positives of locking in the future
cost of college tuition at today's rate
but has the downsides that if my
daughter chooses to go out of state that
the prepay plan will only cover the
equivalent cost of in-state tuition
while the 529 plan I will I will have to
consider what the cost of tuition plant
tuition is starting in 2034 which plan
fits closest with the Ramsay plan we
tell people never do Prepaid College
never
you've identified one of the reasons
your daughter might choose to go out of
state she also might choose to go to
trade school she also might choose a lot
of different things the other reason
anytime you prepay anything
like for instance a funeral
or tuition or anything
over a long period of time
your rate of return on your money
your interest rate if you will is the
inflation rate of that item so if you
prepaid bread
you know what you would make you put a
thousand dollars in bread you prepaid
your bread bill before you know and you
get free bread the rest because you
bought it ahead of time for five years
okay you know however much bread goes up
if it goes up four percent a year then
you're making four percent on your money
if it goes up 18 a year you're making 18
of your money College tuition has for
the last 75 years averaged 7.2 percent
so that's what you would average on your
money and mutual funds have averaged 11
and a half to 12 percent the stock
market has so a you're not making as
much as you would on good mutual funds
at a regular 529 like we tell you to buy
um B she could go out of state and
here's one we could add to this this is
the whole higher ed discussion right now
how many of you think
out there in America today raise your
hands we want to see them
how many of you think that with the Epic
student loan crisis that we have
and then uh the fact that colleges
attempted to charge the same tuition to
put people through online classes during
covid
and uh
now even when they're going back to
school they're having a less than
Stellar experience in many cases
um
the campuses are out of control in a lot
of cases
how many of you think that uh College
is um it's kind of under attack
like I think higher Ed's you know this
idea that they they went for about 50
years they could charge whatever they
wanted to charge but now everybody
suddenly thinks they suck that was
exactly my thought is I'm not sure that
college is going to look the same in 15
years and I don't think it should no I
don't think it should the system even if
it does I don't think it's going to cost
as much right that's exactly what I mean
I don't think it's going to go up seven
percent faster than anything else has
gone up like it has been I think those
days are done because people are
tired of being screwed price-wise by
higher ed and
um so I think there's going to be some
Marketplace pressure on their ability to
increase tuition hand over fist which
means your prepayment
might only make four percent rather than
seven percent I think kovid woke
everyone up now everybody's going hey
wait a minute why are we just blindly
accepting these prices and doing
whatever it takes to pay it like that
doesn't make a whole lot of sense now
that being said I definitely think you
know obviously we all believe saving for
college is important but the Prepaid
Plan specifically really lock you in
versus a traditional 529 there's a lot
more flexibility there if if higher ed
is not able to continue their price
increases your return on investment here
is going to be nominal and that's my
that's a that's a new thing that I've
never said before because I always felt
like tuition was just going to keep
going up and I was right it kept going
up but we've had they've had a little
bit of a perfect storm hit them between
people waking up with borrowed future
and you know the documentary that's
number one documentary last year
um and we're teaching people that uh
stirring up a Ruckus In America that
that you know all degrees are not good
degrees a degree in left-handed puppetry
for 250 000 is stupid
and everybody's starting to say that out
loud now because you end up you know
working
I don't know 250 000 in student loan
debt and working as a barista because
you can't get a job because you're the
thing you studied nobody gives a crap
about you got a degree in you know uh
German polka history or something and
then you wonder why America doesn't owe
you a living when people are also waking
up to the fact that you don't have to go
to a 50 or 75 000 school to be
successful in life like that is not a
Golden Ticket like it's not a guarantee
just because you know you went to XYZ
fancy school that you're automatically
going to get the big expensive job like
that's just not guaranteed starting to
realize that um you know I I went to the
doctor this morning I have no idea where
that lady graduated from college
she may have started her first two years
at Community College I do not know where
she got her empty
but I left there you know much better
off medically you know that's why I went
so there you go I do not know where my
dentist went to school I have no idea I
have all my teeth
but I don't know where he went to school
so well here's the thing I don't want to
knock fancy private schools you know I
do I mean I went to Vanderbilt I love
Vander you went to Vanderbilt for free
right okay and that's my point is get
the best education you can afford if you
can get a full ride to Vanderbilt if you
can get a full ride to an Ivy League
school great but if you can't afford
that there's no shame there and you can
get a great education and a great job go
into Community College first then
transferring to a public university like
where you go to school is not what's
going to make you successful you are
what makes you successful ding ding
there's a secret sauce right there
preach it sister I like it that's how it
works I love that the education system
is getting challenged I hope we're
having a totally different conversation
10 years from now about all the change
that's happened well I mean anytime you
have blind acceptance of something then
you get blind people that accept it I
mean it's just it's just oh God
so yeah it's uh and the stupids but
stuff you people are allowing to go on
on these campuses in the name of
whatever
good Lord who wants to send your child
into the Cesspool like that but Dave a
college needs a rock wall and a lazy
river
yeah yeah
under 20 000 extra dollars a year so
answer to your question Michelle or
Michael
um is
um
529 where you pick the mutual funds and
they don't move unless you move them
and you do that with your smart investor
Pro you do not do Prepaid College
because they're locked into one certain
State you do not do Prepaid College
because you are locked into college your
daughter might want to be a computer
coder and you don't need four years
of college to do that you need code
school to do that it's a different thing
so that that's you know and we do not
know what's going to happen to hire it I
do not think it's I do not think
education is bad but I do not think all
education has a Marketplace value either
as a matter of fact I'm positive German
polka history does not have a
Marketplace value the only job there is
for German polka history is teaching
other people German polka history that's
the only job there is and so it's a
pretty narrow nuanced thing not even
sure it's an actual degree but it's kind
of fun to make fun of it so anyway but
yeah so that's the point so you know if
you're but it is is a four-year Business
Degree a good idea if you're going to be
in business you bet you're going to
learn I got a lot of good stuff
so all education is not bad we're not
throwing the baby out with the bathwater
but I'm just telling you this Baby's in
trouble it's been misbehaving and so uh
I would not do Prepaid College ever but
for sure in this environment I wouldn't
do it this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
Ellis Ramsey personality is my co-host
today you hear me say it all the time
everyone needs a will that's true it's a
basic adult responsibility and there's
just no good excuse to not have one now
it's a good time of the year as we
approach the first of the year to reset
some things in your life getting your
will done is one of them and you've
heard me recommend an online will as the
fastest most cost effective way to get
your will taken care of but I get a lot
of questions asking if a simple online
will is right for everyone's situation I
get that what if you need a trust or you
need a mirror will or what kinds of
Power of attorneys do you need will
those questions in mind our team built a
quiz to help you find the right option
for for you you get custom results on
the quiz and
um like where you're married where are
you married where do you live even the
size of your estate and you'll
understand exactly what you need for
your specific situation it is a free
quiz
so go to
ramsaysolutions.com
Will's quiz check it out for yourself
and it'll start you on the process of
getting the right
will in place and you need to do that
now
Dan is in Lima Ohio hi Dan welcome to
the Ramsay show
thanks Dave for taking my call sure
what's up appreciate it well I recently
um had knee surgery both both Total
knees so and as I'm going to physical
therapy and I have December 2nd as I'm
going to physical therapy they're
telling me I can no longer kneel and I
can no longer climb and I am a carpenter
and that's what I do so it's like okay I
have to do something different
um I do have options I can go ahead and
retire I have to take a penalty and that
would draw approximately Thirty one
hundred and eighteen dollars a month
until the day I die
so that's not a bad option but it's like
I want to make sure I do the right
option if I would make it until 62 I'd
grow almost 3 800 a month how old are
you
I'll be 58 in January
yeah a union carpenter I take it
yes Carpenter yes okay
so the rent Rave about uh college and
everything else like that for you people
that ain't smart the union trade is a
great thing pipefitter boiling paper
Carpenter it's all a great thing yeah
what do you what do you make a year back
when you were
still uh swinging a hammer
I make about 65 a year good for you you
know how much overtime I work which is a
little you know usually a lot
do you have any other savings
yes we I also had a the carpenter Union
comes with also an annuity and I've got
like 34 000 in that and I've pulled that
out of the carpenters union and put it
in Edward Jones in stocks
but you know as you can see the last
year the stock market has not been
friendly
to my uh Investments there so
um I would like to know more about
switching it to a a mutual fund of some
sort but you know we'll
be decent to my year like this year
um well I mean you would be selling
something that's down and buying
something that's down so it's as good a
time to do it as any
as far as that switching that over goes
okay so you're you're not going to be a
carpenter anymore and
um you're gonna be making Thirty One
hundred dollars right
right so what are you gonna do now
well
and that's the thing I could go do
something else for a couple years and
I'd like to because I would like to pay
off my mortgage
I mean you're young you got a lot of
things you can do you just not be a
carpenter you're gonna be something else
and this is what we call an encore
career it's the second act
yes yeah I mean you're 58 you still have
lots of time even even just in general I
think we had this conversation a few
weeks ago where it's nice to keep your
brain active and moving and doing things
even if it's not the career you've known
for so many years just to have that
stimulation versus I bet you all know
super super cold days or the super super
hot days you had something pop into your
head you'd like to do someday
you know I messed my shoulder I got
another story I messed my shoulder up in
13. so I am
went back got six or if my rotator
dropped my library I took off my biceps
so I get it fixed I go back to work a
year later same pains you know so go see
the doctor doctor says you need to do
something different your Carpenter is
tearing your shoulder up so I started my
own business I started a Matco tool
franchise and I did that for like five
years and I had a son-in-law that moved
back from Florida and I was like I was
like come on with me give this a try and
he did awesome at it so I set him up in
that business and I went back being a
carpenter
so and then recently my knees you know I
knew they were bad you know and then you
go get them so if you can do a Mac Tool
business you can do another business
right
yeah but I'm telling you those days that
you were laid up in the hospital or
those days it was too hot to be outside
or too cold to be outside and you were
out there anyway you were thinking
Someday I'm gonna go do blank blank
blank blank blank and you ought to go do
that now
that's all I'm saying you're gonna
you're not a carpenter anymore your dog
told you you're done do you think you
should go ahead and take the early
penalty and get the 31 18 or wait on
that like do another career that fully
funds his life I mean yeah if you can
just eat if you can make enough to live
and not take it now and take it at 65
that's fine uh that's going to be a lot
better deal for him
um but yeah or take it now and still go
get money right well only one's okay
yeah if you if you do take it now it you
could still get a job that's a little
bit more of a passion project like if
you want to go you know volunteer not
volunteer but work in a non-profit or
something like that I guess that's the
case now I want to go make some money so
get a real like yeah he ran a business
making money with a tool business before
so best case scenario he waits till 62.
don't touch that and then let it get to
where it's 3 800. either one's fine but
if he takes it now it does take the
pressure off trying to make the other
thing happen immediately because you got
money to eat with yeah so I'm probably
going to take it now just for that
reason but I'm still gonna say and go
start another thing man yeah you've done
it before they're gonna kick your feet
up on on 3 000 bucks a month you're not
done at that so you need some more than
that sure and even just beyond the money
you talked you told the story recently
about your fishing friend who took off
for a while then he got fat and then
went back to work yeah and he didn't
enjoy it a lot of people you know they
get all that time back and then they're
like wait a minute I want to do
something I'm excited to do something I
want to get out of the house
that's exactly right so there's there's
a benefit of that and I I just think
you know um
all I'm saying is you you've been
through all this pain physically
and and now you don't really have the
option of doing this anymore so the only
question is whether you take the
retirement now or you wait and take it
later doesn't really matter either one's
gonna be fine but neither cases enough
so you're going to be create you need to
go create some income doing something
else that's the important part of this
particular
discussion by the way folks it is good
to stop and recognize this okay
Beaufort did a book called half time
and he said that uh men in particular
the data tells us
spend the first half of their life in
acquisition in the second half of their
life seeking significance women too but
he had the study he did was on men and
the research that he had was on that and
if you don't reach for significance in
that second half you tend to get off the
rails and um you know get into drugs or
you know run off with secretary in a red
convertible or whatever that kind of
stuff right so you so guys you got to
need to aim at something in the second
half now sometimes your second half
starts at 30. sometimes it starts at 58.
you know what's your second half it does
it's not an age thing it was there's a
like an arc to your career an arc to
what you're doing in the first half of
it is acquisition the second half of
significance
the important part of that conversation
is the other piece of data that's out
there that we do know is that your
highest the typical person your highest
income potential decade is the decade of
your 50s
50 to 60. because that's the point in
your life that all of your experience in
your career field
is now valuable
and before then you've been Gathering
that experience by making mistakes now
all of those mistakes are called
experience and and you you really know
things that you just didn't know before
they put you in a sweet spot to go
really cha-ching and so that's why this
Encore career thing comes up is very
very very important that puts us out of
the Ramsey Show in the books
foreign
[Music]
ER you can find all of our shows with
the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire backed catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving in storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where that is dumb cash is
king and the paid off Home Mortgage has
taken the place of the BMW as the status
symbol of choice we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships Christina
Ellis number one best-selling author
Ramsay personality is my co-host today
as we talk to you about your life and
your money Merry Christmas America
thanks for being with us the phone
number here is triple eight eight two
five five two two five the call is free
and some say the advice is worth exactly
what you pay for it all right we're
going to start of this hour with Luke in
Fort Wayne Indiana hi Luke welcome to
the Ramsey Show
hi Dave thanks for taking my call it's
an honor honor to speak with you sir how
can we help
um so I was calling to get some advice
um because I'm getting married in six
months and moving out of home for my
parents and
I'm wondering what you would advise is
kind of like a
nest egg or just a small it feels like I
should have some money set aside to pay
for you know like furniture and you know
the deposit and things like that
do you have an emergency fund right now
I do I have a thousand dollars I'm on
baby step two okay wonderful
well Dave I am curious how much beyond
the deposit so you have your deposit for
the apartment
I mean if you're on baby step two
I'm thinking pretty cheap but Dave
what's your take yeah you need to well I
mean basically it's not do you need more
than a thousand dollars in savings uh
that's not the question uh the question
is how are you gonna fund the setup
and um you show you what do you make
what's your income
fifty thousand okay and so you've got
the money coming in you don't have any
overhead to mount anything right
correct yeah so you're going to slow
down your debt snowball enough to cover
your deposits to get your utilities set
up to buy a garage sale couch
and a Craigslist kitchen table
and uh get some dishes while you're at
that garage sale uh so you got something
to eat off of and uh you know just set
the place up cheap and then uh then you
can upgrade from there as you go along
towards the marriage date and and with
the uh with the wedding gifts as well
that'll help put a little nicer things
in the cabinets right
um get your toaster and whatever else
you got to have there right so uh you
know but but the big things you're gonna
have to do is avoid just go retail you
know spend twelve thousand dollars on
furniture you're not going to do that
you don't have twelve thousand dollars
whatever yeah I think you really need to
go in with like a Frugal mindset right
rather than asking the question like how
much you know should I have in a typical
scenario it's like you know how cheap
can we do this in a way that we still
get to live in a place that's not you
know a terrible spot but how can we save
the most money in this situation I mean
you know talk to the apartment complex
find out what your deposit is you know
what that you know what that is you know
what your first month rent is they're
all going to be due up front you also
got to check with your utility companies
find out exactly what those are those
are fixed numbers and then just give
yourself a used furniture budget and
just get in there and start with nothing
and start you know super super super
cheap and keep working your debt
snowball uh all the while who's paying
for the wedding
my family I'm paying for a little bit of
it I've already paid for the honeymoon
um but the the wedding isn't much of an
expense I'd say less than probably five
hundred dollars okay how much debt do
you all have
uh so I only have like ten thousand uh
but my fiance has about 80 000 so we
have ninety thousand well there's not a
wee yet after you're married we have
ninety thousand but yeah right now she's
paying hers you're paying yours until
the actual wedding occurs and then we
combine everything and we attack from
there but I mean the two of you can go
shop for a garage sale couch
um together and you're you're buying it
but you're both gonna end up sitting on
it
um certainly after marriage and so go
pick some of these things out have an
adventure with this stuff and you know
Sharon and I did this stuff Luke I mean
we got married it was uh if you go to
the rich end of town there are people
that will put a eight thousand dollar
nine thousand dollar leather couch out
on their uh in their garage sale for for
a hundred bucks because they've got to
get out of the way literally the kitchen
table we still use to this day I got for
free off Craigslist from a lady in the
rich part of town who just didn't want
it yeah just trying to get rid of it it
was literally fully wood like a fourteen
hundred dollar table that she didn't
want to take the time to take somewhere
else so I was like I'll take it and I
just it does make me think of that
season when we were first you know
married when I was first getting out in
the world even with Apartments I would
literally just refresh apartment
websites trying to find deals so I I had
my eyes set on this really nice
apartment that was it was I'm gonna date
myself a little in Nashville it was 900
a month and I was like I cannot afford
that I kept refreshing keep refreshing
one time it refreshed and they said they
had a special for 550 a month and I
jumped on it I went in that day so it's
like I was just so hungry to find
something that I could afford that it
was less about you know like what's the
typical apartment price can I afford
that I was aggressive in trying to find
the best deal turns the whole thing into
a game yeah it's actually yeah let's
finish the game it's a game but how how
cheap can we do this and how how great a
deal can we get what kind of bargain can
we get and you know that's how you get
started and and the good news is is that
this is not a forever couch no unless
you get a really nice one like our
kitchen table it's still not forever
cash because it's not your couch I mean
it's just it's just a it's a hundred
dollar thing to sit on right or a 50
thing to sit on that's all it is and
you're gonna you're gonna upgrade later
and you're gonna upgrade later and you
know you're gonna move and you're gonna
do all kinds of stuff and so it's you
know two years from now none of this
will still be there you will have moved
on now in your case you've kept the
table because it was a very cool table
to start with but yeah so but the uh but
I'm just saying I don't we don't have
any of that furniture 40 years later
that we started with I'm just telling
you not one stick of it that I'm aware
of so um but that you know it's okay
it's just a place to start so the point
is you don't need a bigger emergency
fund how much do I need to have in
savings no you just need a budget to
move in that encompasses your deposits
and a little bit of setup costs for
Furnishings uh from the garage sale in
the rich people into town all right
let's go to Tim in Camden hi Tim how are
you
hey real good thank you guys for uh
taking my call today uh I got a quick
one for you here
um I have had a recent change of
employment I am now in the sales
industry I'm a uh outside sales guy and
I'm traveling our large State here and I
have an opportunity coming up to get
into uh right now the vehicle that I
have I'm putting I don't know 45
000 miles a year on this thing wow and
so I'm going to go through these cars
pretty quick I do have a payment going
on on this vehicle right now I have a
stipend from my employer I get mileage
but a new plan or a new possibility is
coming out is that I have the
possibility in the future for like for
160 some odd dollars a month for a
mid-sized vehicle I can lease the
vehicle through my employer they take
care of all the stuff uh you know you
can't drive a car that cheap
that's that's cheaper than you can drive
a car on your own
so do it you're destroying a car a year
that's 50 000 miles a year you're
destroying its value you're running the
maintenance costs up you run up
everything so you can't 160 bucks a
month and they're Furnishing everything
yeah that's called an employee benefit
that's not a lease as long as you're out
of it when you quit there I'm in do it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
Christina Ellis Ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today last minute gifts do not
have to be less meaningful
if you're still looking for a last
minute gift we can help we won't tell on
you
instead of grabbing a random gift card
at CVS oh Lord help you seriously you
were going to do that weren't you yeah
don't do that okay you can give to you
can give a gift that inspires life
change uh like coming to one of our Live
Events live event tickets make a great
stocking stuffer they're downloadable
and of course you can buy them right up
until the last moment just print them
off right so we're heading down the road
for our Building Wealth live event tour
for the spring here where me and the
other Ramsey personalities George camel
Rachel Cruz Ken Coleman Dr John deloney
will walk through our simple but proven
plan to get out of debt and build wealth
we're going to kick off the tour in
Nashville on January 12th and then
Indianapolis Indiana February 16th
Austin Texas February 23rd Salt Lake
City Utah April 24th Anaheim California
May 2nd these events are selling out uh
you do not want to wait around on this
even if you're not doing it for
Christmas event passes start at just 49
and you can take a few extra if you want
to get a group deal on it just holler at
us we'll make you a group deal I mean
we're we're up for getting you there we
want you to see this stuff and to learn
this material
ramseysolutions.com events
ramseysolutions.com
events Elena is in Charlotte hi Elena
how are you
hi I'm good how are you better than I
deserve how can we help
question so my husband and I are
debating paying off the house
um I know you've had this one before or
um investing money she
we're on I think we've completed up the
baby step four now
um he likes to have cash on hand just
you know if the market does go down and
we want to buy another house for
investment purposes
um fully funding but
we're just kind of in the predicament do
we pay off off now do we pay it off in
chunks like throw a big chunk this year
then another chunk next year
want to get your thoughts
uh how long you been listening to this
show
um a while and he sends me I I think I
know what you're gonna say but I kind of
also let him to hear it
okay I mean if you're gonna work our
plan you already know what you're
supposed to do right
if you're going to work your plan then
you get to make up your own plan
right
so but we know from data and 30 years of
doing this that the shortest distance
between where you are and wealthy is to
get everything paid off and stop
borrowing money because you get control
of your most powerful wealth building
tool which is your income
and you know the vast majority of the
millionaires that we studied in the
millionaires largest study a millionaire
has ever done had paid off their home
early
and um and it frees up that house
payment I mean when you start investing
a house payment it turns into a million
dollars so fast it's scary
when you were talking about what he
wants to do in terms of investing did
you mention the possibility of getting
another house I thought I heard that
yeah
using the cash on hand to buy a rental
instead of paying off their home
yeah so because we're Max I mean we Max
our 401ks
um we put money in our roths
so but instead of you know putting all
eggs in one basket that was kind of our
next especially if the market does go
down yeah so you've been listening to
the show for a while has he been
listening for a while or what's kind of
his attitude towards the baby stuff he
he he likes and and I laugh when you
guys say you know the feeling of having
zero debt if you do pay it off he just
has a certain dollar threshold that he
likes to see in savings I think he's
just scared to see that Google event
um so I think he's just the comfort of
having cash on hand how much cash have
you got
um
Savings of about 300 thousand dollars
uh just is it just sitting in a high
yield savings account or what what are
y'all doing with the money right now
yeah okay yeah and that's costing you
2500 bucks a month right there
opportunity cost that's dumber than a
rock that's not comforting that's just
stupid
how much is your mortgage
um we're on a 15-year it's about now
what's your balance
oh 205. pay it off today
now this is ridiculous you'd still have
a ton of money left you're still sitting
on a hundred thousand dollars what is it
makes you comfortable my God
pay that off today
you're sitting there making one percent
on your money
and calling that comfortable
no no no no
what do you guys make you must make five
or six hundred thousand what do you make
no um like four yeah I figured Lord
honey y'all do whatever you want to do
but you called here
um
yeah this is your your situation
financial planners uh worldwide would
call you ridiculous sitting on 300 Grand
cash at one percent
I mean I I don't think you're gonna find
anybody who goes oh that's wise
um I mean I I like having cash around I
believe in liquidity I believe in having
an emergency fund I believe in having
access to your money but um yeah you
guys need a ride check today Hey listen
pay it off and if you hate it you hate
being debt free with only 100 000 in the
bank in four or five months just go get
you another mortgage you'll feel better
you'll never do that by the way once you
pay it off you're gonna go oh I was
completely getting my that was just no
way I'm going back right well and they
make they asked earlier what the numbers
were oh I'm like they make enough money
they could buy that rental property soon
they can get the bank account back up
soon I'm like hacking my brain you make
400k you can buy another rental by the
end of the year right in cash
and not and never have any debt
I mean you're sitting on a hundred
thousand dollars after we do this deal
you need to pay the shots off
before that's the sun goes down
Merry Christmas
do it right now
oh my gosh I think that I think that's a
good word gosh that's yeah my brain is
like I'm racking my brain trying to
think through any reasons or arguments
that he might have
that are valid there's not any the night
that this is just
what what happens in this situation is
to get they make a lot of money I knew
it I could smell it you make five six
hundred dollars just 400 okay yeah wow
okay so they make a ton of money and
they work like crazy people they work
hard they put a lot of hours in probably
carrying a lot of stress
and the that pile of money does give you
comfort
when you're working that hard because
you can if anything if you just want to
do something just do it that it gives
you lots of options and margin and that
kind of thing and so what he's receiving
from that is a comfort it is an
emotional Comfort but what you're
trading it for is the emotional
discomfort of losing 30 to 40 000 a year
return on 300 Grand sitting there doing
nothing
I mean 40 000 bucks a year is
substantial loss that's huge you know
and uh I mean 30 000 at or three hundred
thousand at ten percent thirty thousand
so I mean whatever you want to calculate
it at but thirty thousand that's that's
that's serious money and that's a nice
vacation I'm just saying that's a nice
vacation yeah and so what what it's a
lot of things what what you don't
realize when you're in a situation and
Elena's situation is
um that the comfort and the margin and
the flexibility that all that cash gives
you intellectually
the trade-off is emotionally you haven't
realized you are carrying weight with
that mortgage
and you have you just kind of set it in
the back of your mind but it's still in
your mind and as Dr deloni talks about
your body knows that it's there and so
when you pay this off you're going to
get a different kind of peace
that is actually more thorough a more
thorough piece than you're getting from
this pile of cash the cash is a mirage
that's what I'm saying this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
Christine Alice Ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today in the lab
of Ramsey Solutions on the debt freeze
stage Jason and Shannon are with us hey
guys Merry Christmas Merry Christmas
good to have you all where do you live
Minnesota all right what part of
Minnesota uh Minneapolis well Lakeville
Minneapolis yeah cool well good to have
you welcome to Nashville and uh you
apparently sent some cold weather our
way it's coming the day after tomorrow
or something it's gonna get like super
cold this isn't cold
it's going down to single digits in two
days here so way to go guys all right
how much debt did you pay off so we paid
off about 1.6 million oh
my God
okay uh and uh how long did this take
well backtrack a little we we actually
were on your plan in Michigan we started
our family there and then stepped into
business with my father-in-law
and I had called you and I was still in
Michigan which would have been like
let's say 2008 and you told me not to go
into partnership
but I did
and um moved from out of state to a new
state so we we tried a different way of
borrowing money and building businesses
and
get into a partnership and then my wife
uh actually got into a terrible accident
hit by a semi with my daughters and
um
made it pretty difficult
they shaved off my hair took off my
skull
I was in a coma for 11 weeks not good I
was just getting worse
pretty much a vegetable
it was lots of prayer the reason I was
came came out of my coma I used to be in
a wheelchair
we learned how to walk talk eat all of
it only Jesus oh my God all him all
Jesus only how long ago was that
2015.
seven years
and I mean you're like completely
yeah I had neurosurgery come in and tell
me to pull the plug up all four of them
and I just
I knew the Lord of healer and I needed
people to pray
wow
that's amazing all right God is good
amen amen way to go y'all what a story
and so
you were deeply in debt at this point
and in a partnership with your dad and
the boat was sinking and meanwhile
you're in a coma and there's things what
kind of a business uh actually Jimmy
John's yeah okay
all right
huh so you had a bunch of franchises did
yes sir how'd you get out what happened
so we got up to eight locations and um
because that's a good franchise it is
great great franchise a lot of integrity
uh Southern half of Minnesota had a lot
of ground to cover to get to each one
and just started putting
C plus people and a spots and the
numbers just don't work as you're taking
loans out on multiple stores
so we decided to divide with my
father-in-law which was in itself an
answer to prayer just to give us four
and him for and at that point was about
end of 2017 that we really started to
just tackle okay how do we get out of
this mess because it was Heavy I mean it
was sleepless nights two years after the
accident
yes split the stores up correct and you
end up with 1.6 million in debt is that
all on the stores just about uh some was
my home yeah I mean there was more debt
with all eight but he assumed four of
them and so yeah you got you got you cut
the Hat in half because you got the
partnership exactly okay
so what did what did this journey look
like how did you pay off that much debt
so
um
like I say sleepless nights and I began
to just get into stores and try to just
manage what I had and figure out what
this would look like to pay it off what
the time frame would look like
um while she's at home trying to help
with some bill pay and just
not driving my oldest turned 16 was old
enough to help it was just hard to be on
the road when
you got one adult that can drive
wow so you just turned the stores around
I I did some
um I mean covid actually really helped
as far as we already did pick up and
delivery so you didn't have to reinvent
that piece but I had actually had them
for sale in 2019 and didn't end up
closing the deal
uh until September of 2022.
so I sold three of the four I just
operate one and may look at doing
another one now with cash uh two stores
in our hometown and not have all the
travel and the overhead
wow you all are amazing your story is so
powerful and just so encouraging to all
the people who are listening who are in
the ditch right now who feel like you
know their life is just a mess and they
can't get out what what would you tell
those people who just feel so
discouraged
I start my day with Jesus
and
hard work
um
But ultimately Dave's philosophy had
just paying off debt like let me try it
I can go get a mortgage I can go get
sbas I can go get lots of loans if I
want but I want to at least try this
side of the fence to say we paid it off
so to have kind of a goal and to be able
to reach it
um
thank you Jesus amen 1.6 million you
guys not only reached it you crushed it
well the hole was pretty big but um it
was nice to have assets to be able to
sell so that took a lot of work just to
make them valuable enough to sell and
chose good locations and just was able
to have an exit strategy and still a
great relationship with my in-laws and
um
so very very grateful just to be able to
be that example to my kids wow but even
before we sold those doors we had worked
off paying off all the debts there's no
debt but our mortgage our home
okay so you were clear up until then and
then that final closing last last fall
took care of it
yes this fall yeah yeah wow just about
three months ago yeah and that's one
thing I'd say Dave is that I and we've
listened to your show a ton over the
years but the people that do get to do a
death free screaming are here right
after their mortgage it doesn't quite
sink in until your few months down the
road and realize like
right
it'll just come to my mind like the
mortgage no the mortgage is gone yeah
you got a paid for house or paid for a
business you've got to be over a million
dollar net worth easy actually we were
on your millionaire steam hour here
maybe two months ago okay so we're at
about 3.5 yeah I thought so okay way to
go guys
thank you
fabulous Shannon are you driving again I
am all right how long ago did you start
driving
um I had had eight seizures so I haven't
drove and I've really
four or five months ago oh okay just
recently all right cool because with a
brain injury I started having seizures
unfortunately and I've had a total of
eight now but I haven't had one in a
year and four months so I'm very happy
about that hey man that's good news a
lot to be thankful for yeah 2022 was a
big year it is yes yeah Wow way to go
y'all thank you whoa that's impressive
all right we have a uh the living I'm
sorry go ahead so I do want to say
though for people that are doing this
trust me you guys can do this it gets
frustrating but just stay focused you
can do this it feels so good just keep
at it you can do it you can do it you
can do it
so the overall I didn't finish up I
guess but the uh the overall time I
guess for really from the it's from 15
so it's a seven year Journey we would
say to get out of debt well in about
five years when we actually started to
get out of debt the first two years of
her coming out of the hospital was just
trying to that's right you're still in
the partnership right 17. okay all right
so five years and um your your range of
income during that five years uh varied
anywhere from probably 200 up to about
400. okay but the income isn't really
What mattered it was to say all the
assets that's what did yes sir yeah so
the getting rid of the three store three
of the four stores but there's a lot
more profit when you don't have the
overhead
I've heard the rumor
well done all right we've got the live
and give bundle for you the baby steps
millionaires book The Total Money
Makeover book and Financial Peace
University in your case for you to give
away and I will pass that on and you'll
be able to pass it on way to go Jason
and Shannon 1.6 million in five years
making 200 to 400 count it down let's
hear a debt free scream three two one
[Applause]
that's how it's done man what a story
powerful this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Philippians 4 12 I know what it is to be
in need
and I know what it is to have plenty I
have learned the secret of being content
in any and every situation whether
well-fed or hungry whether living in
plenty or in want
Oscar Wilde said true contentment is not
having everything but in being satisfied
with everything you have
Christine Alice Ramsey personality is my
co-host today Alexandra is with us in
Oakland California hi Alexandra how are
you
how are you Dave
Nina hi
no then we deserve Merry Christmas how
can we help
um so basically I just wanted to know
what you think is the best time when
dating like
um is to ask about finances like
financial goals debts income and things
like that
are you currently dating someone right
now
no
question and so it's like for future
person that you meet
yeah and just like when you're on a
dating like you know when you're meeting
new new people and stuff like that
um that's a great question Dave I'm
curious about your tag because I haven't
dated in 50 years I don't have any idea
well and what's funny is I've only had
one date for 50 years what's funny too
though is like we've had so many people
come through recently on the debt-free
stage that said that they talked about
you on their first date yeah that has
come up I don't know that that's your
recommendation no it's not I can't I
can't really say Ramsey is Romance I'm
just it just doesn't scream Romance
um maybe for grown-ups I don't know but
uh oh my gosh I don't um
so I
trying to think how how I would coach
like one of my kids
or something because what you're looking
for when you're dating is
um I mean you're either just out there
goofing off or you're actually looking
for
someone to marry right and so
[Music]
um
if you have Financial things or anything
in your life values wise
you should have a lot of things that are
deal breakers
uh
maybe it's not romantic maybe it's
efficiency but I'd want to get to the
deal breakers fairly
quick just to not waste time
I don't know I'm making this up on the
spot on it what do you think Christina
so when my husband and I were dating we
went to this church service together at
one point where the pastor gave us a
challenge and he said if you are single
or if you're dating right now if you
start dating someone I want you to go
home tonight and sit down with that
person and lay everything on the table
like lay out all your drama lay out any
type of baggage you have anything hidden
your financial stuff this was like three
weeks into dating for us because they
were like if like you said if that's
something you can't handle it's like you
know the baggage early on like you know
early on whether or not that person has
a history whether they have like things
that are deal breakers for you so we
literally went home that night we went
over actually I think we did a like a
coffee house or something and we sat
down and we said we said okay here's the
stuff here's my stuff here's my junk can
you handle it and obviously near nearly
15 years later here we are we're still
good but I think that's an important
practice to kind kind of go you know I
don't want to find out a year into
dating when I'm already in love that
they have something that I can't
tolerate okay I'm here's an interesting
idea I'm just I'm making this up on the
spot I do this a lot on this show y'all
don't know that but um okay the four
things we do know data the four things
that if you're in agreement on these
four things you have a very high
likelihood of your marriage not only
lasting but prospering money
religion kids whether to have them and
how to treat them and dealing with the
in-laws
the extended family because in every
family there's crazy and if you think
there's not it's you so
um that you know that that you need to
know how to deal with crazy because
crazy's out there somewhere and um so
we're gonna if you can deal with the
four things extended family kids
religion
and money if you're in agreement on
those you will prosper so I would want
to
at some point discuss all of those
things or sooner rather than later but
first date might be weird you know but
um I mean like you know he's going to
pay for your dinner with a credit card
and you go into freak out mode or
something it's over it's over you're an
idiot what are you crazy yeah that's it
it's over we're done wait a minute we
didn't even start okay but yeah
so I don't know what are you thinking
Alexandra
um I mean I I know that a birthday of
course I'm not going to be like well how
much debt are you in but I've always
just like okay well as a second and
third like you said with time I'm like
well I don't want to waste each other's
time like I want us to be on the same
page with like financial goals like what
we want in the future and things like
that so
um I'm thinking like um what Christina
said with
um you know like a week two weeks you
know putting it all on the table like
hey it seems like we really like each
other like let's really like what what
are they
what are my non-negotiables okay and I'd
want to know those
um you know like if you never want to
have kids and this person wants to have
17 kids
that's probably a deal breaker you know
for most people right
um and you know if you uh you know
absolutely cannot stand the idea of
being in debt and they think that
um you should go borrow 10 million
dollars and buy investment real estate
off of tick tock suggestions
um then you know you probably don't have
a fit right and so if you're on Extremes
in other words that's going to wake you
up
um you know your spiritual walk would be
a big one that'd be a big one
um as a deal breaker because that's
going to inform almost every other area
of your life
and so
um you know if they're go if they are of
a different religion or no religion
they're atheist or whatever that's going
to inform that belief system and it is a
belief system either way is going to
inform parenting it's going to inform
communication it's going to inform
everything how you treat each other the
whole bit and so yeah that's very
interesting but yeah I I it does feel
like that
um
uh uh you're not just data is you're not
recre if you're not doing recreational
dating okay if you're dating for the
purpose of uh what you would have called
in the 1950s courting right or something
like that for the purpose of looking for
a mate to marry then you're you're going
to get there sooner than later on all
the non-negotiables and money would just
be one of them
one I think it's better to get there
sooner rather than later of course not
awkwardly on the first date but sooner
rather than later so you're not wasting
time because it's like if you get to
eight months and it's a non-negotiable
that sucks the 17 kids if you don't
realize that until you're dating some of
these people are putting like FPU
graduate on their dating website the
thing like oh you know or like I do the
Ramsay stuff or something like that and
so it's like oh I can't stand those
people I'm they're all a cult and so I'm
not going out with that person right
that makes sense I mean that's at least
it's a filter yeah I was gonna say it
filters it normally so um I mean we we
get Negative press sometimes and so but
we kind of like it
because it's a filter because at least
people know who we are and you go I
don't like that okay then you wouldn't
want to be over here you know it's kind
of a deal breaker the same kind of a
date you know different different things
so
um yeah that's that's very interesting
though maybe maybe we should have a
Ramsay dating service we have have had
lots of people request a Ramsey dating
service so many so that we actually
considered it and said no
whoa yeah it comes up all the time
that's just weird but yeah but it does
come up it comes up a lot so uh there we
go and
um oh my goodness wow yeah that's uh
yeah
it's interesting I feel like it is kind
of nice to have those filters because it
is such a different world of dating even
15 years for me and my husband and you
and Sharon it's like with the internet
and so many filters and being able to
choose things it's like being able to
just like have that information up front
would be nice for it to be like hey I'm
debt free or hey you know I see this
what like yeah I'm not the dead is a
filter like a hundred thousand dollars
in student loan debt it's kind of like
saying I've got two children
you would want to know that you would
want to know yeah fairly quickly you
know yeah and then you get to decide if
you want to go forward with two children
or 400 000 either one I mean that's part
of the process well that puts this hour
of the Ramsey Show in the books good job
Christina Austin Finn James Zack and
Andrew in the booth the booth dudes they
make it happen we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the Prince of Peace Christ
Jesus
foreign
have you been inspired to make a change
with your money want to know where to
start take our three minute money quiz
to get a plan you can follow go to
ramsesolutions.com and search for get
started to get a plan for your money
[Music]